ابواب مملكتهم ليست مصابه فالحروب
والتغيرات المناخيه اعاست في بيئتهم ايضا
خرابا حتى لم تعد قادره على احتواء
المخلوقات الحيه التي تقطنها غير ان موت
هذه الحيوانات او هربها من موطنها الاصليه
يقلل من التنوع الحيوي للمنطقه ما يؤدي
للتضرر سلسله متكامله تبدا بفقدان وتدهور
الغابات وتلوث المياه والهواء مرورا بتغير
المناخ وصولا الى تهديد صحه الانسان ففي
بحث هو الاوسع عبر التاريخ كشفت جامعه
كوينز بالفاس في ايرلندا ان
28% من الحياه على الارض مهدده حاليا
بالانقراض ودقت ناقوس الخطر فيما يخص
تراجع اعداد اكثر من 70 الف نوعا من
الحيوانات في كل انحاء العالم اي ما يعادل
48% منها
اما اهم اسباب فقدان المواطن الطبيعيه
للتنوع الاحيائي فتعود الى استفحال ظواهر
الاحتباس الحراري مترافقه مع ارتفاع نسب
الغازات الدفيئه بفعل التلوث الصناعي اي
ما تخلفه المصانع والمعامل من نفايات
وسموم في الماء والهواء والتربه
فيما يبقى التاثير الاخطر لانتشار الحروب
واستخدام الاسلحه الفتاكه والمحرمه دوليا
التي تلوث التربه بالاشعاعات لعقود طويله
وفي وقت تتفلت الحلول من الايدي طرحت
الدراسه نفسها برامج واستراتيجيات للحد او
التخفيف من خسائر التنوع الحيويه بينها
حمايه المناطق البريه والمحميات الطبيعيه
والحد من المتاجره غير المشروعه
بالحيوانات والنباتات ومكافحه الصيد
الجائر والتلويث الطبيعه وتسريع التحول
نحو الطاقه المتجدده